- Hi, and welcome.
Hopefully you are here
for Your AI Agent Is Expensive
and Wrong (Let's Fix Both).
If you're not, enjoy the next 60 minutes
and for those of you who I recognize
from past re:Invent or
data and AI Summit talks,
thank you for coming again
and pleasuring us with your presence here.
So (clears throat) my name's Craig Wiley.
I run product management
for AI and ML at Databricks,
joined today by Nic, Vikram, and Marcos,
Nic also from Databricks
and Vikram and Marcos from Conde Nast,
who will talk a little
bit about taking some
of what we're doing, what we talk about
in the first half of this,
about how they've
implemented that successfully
at Conde Nast so far,
so let's dive right in.
So this is what we're gonna do.
We're gonna talk a little bit about why,
why a different approach
to AI agents is needed.
We're gonna go do a big,
thick, long, meaty demo.
Conde Nast will come
up and talk for a bit,
and then we'll finish
off with any questions
and answers that you might have.
If, for some reason, we run out of time,
which is reasonably likely,
then we'll do Q&A up here
until they kick us out and then
we'll do it out in the hall.
So if you have questions,
feel free to keep 'em
and make sure they get answered.
So with that, apologies.
But you are, I believe,
I am contractually forced
to show you this slide, which is,
this is Gartner's annual comparison.
For those of you guys who
don't know, this is really,
I think used, Gartner says
this is used very infrequently
by actual customers and users,
and is mostly used by the
vendors to flex on each other.
And given that I was responsible
for building the AWS stack
and the Google stack,
this was a particularly
exciting flex for me.
But, so with that, let's dive in.
So, our goal at Databricks
is to help democratize data
and AI and that goal has
changed significantly
over just the last two or three years,
as I'm sure you can all imagine
with agentic AI becoming more and more
of a powerful force in the industry.
About three years ago, our CEO,
or I should say yeah, three,
just about three years ago,
little less, about two
and a half years ago,
our CEO actually got up on stage
at our annual conference
and said, in the future,
you're just gonna use natural language
to power Databricks and to use Databricks
and while we're not there today yet,
today on Databricks,
you can build pipelines
with natural language and
jobs with natural language.
You can, you know, build, you can,
you can do Text-to-SQL,
you can now do text to machine learning.
You can now do text to agent.
You can do text to visualization.
So you, while you can't
do kind of text to all
of Databricks, you can get pretty close
with some of the capabilities.
And we'll talk about some of those today.
This is Databricks, by
the way, more or less.
At the lowest level, we have your data
in open formats, in cheap blob storage.
On top of that, we have Unity
Catalog designed not only
to govern and access
control that data layer,
but also designed to really be the brain
and the kind of metadata
collection system to be able
to power some really cool capabilities,
which we'll talk about shortly.
Then you have Agent Bricks,
our ability to orchestrate
and build agents on top of all of this.
And then you have a
series of engines, right?
AI/BI, our business intelligence
capabilities, right?
Our apps capabilities, Lakeflow,
our pipe lining capabilities, Lakehouse,
our data warehouse capabilities,
and Lakebase, our new OLTP capabilities.
I don't know about all of you,
but in my experience,
every data professional
spent some amount of time
early in their career
where they said, you know, oh yeah,
I'll just go get the information
out of the data warehouse.
And they go and they
look and they're like,
hey, the information's
not in the data warehouse
and someone smart in the company said,
yeah, it's in the database.
And you go, wait a
minute, there's two...why?
And you know, they,
oh, well, OLAP and OLTP
and we all just nod and go,
oh yeah, that makes sense.
Those should be separate.
But no, no, they shouldn't be, right?
They should hopefully,
in the fullness of time,
be one thing and so,
you know, it's with that
that we're really excited about
some of those capabilities.
So today we're really gonna
talk about three things.
We're gonna talk about Unity
Catalog for a hot second.
We're gonna talk about AI/BI
and some of the natural
language capabilities
we've brought into that,
because those end up
being really important
to some of our agentic capabilities.
And then we'll dive into Agent Bricks
and what it means to build
an agent with Agent Bricks
and how and why that's
different from building agents,
maybe using other
platforms or other tools.
So this is how I think
about the AI opportunity
sitting in front of all of us right now
is how do I simplify the creation for you
of high quality AI apps and
agents on your data, right?
And we're very clear about what we mean
by high quality, right?
What we mean is we want it to be accurate
and secure enough that
you could implement it
in the path of risk, right?
Either financial risk, maybe
in an internal workflow,
or maybe externally in reputational risk
as you expose it to your
customers or your users, right?
This is really a different goal, right?
Most of my competitors will say,
we wanna simplify the
creation of these systems.
We want to give you one click RAG, right?
But really, and those, that's great.
And listen, if what you're trying to build
is a little personal productivity hack
for you and your colleagues,
those are great tools.
But we see the problem
slightly differently,
which is if you were to go deploy an agent
into the path of risk,
either externally facing
or into some sort of internal workflow
that, at some point, you hope
to be hands off the wheel
and allow it just to run autonomously.
If you expect to be
able to deploy an agent
into those environments,
your CFO is gonna have questions, right?
Your CFO is gonna ask two things, right?
They're gonna ask if you
can govern this thing.
And by govern, I don't just
mean access management,
I don't just mean, you know,
who can call the agent.
I mean, who can call, I do
mean who can call the agent,
but I also mean what
precisely is the agent capable
of doing at every
intermediate step, right?
What are all the systems it has access to?
What are, so what's it capable
of and what is it doing?
How, what's your strategy for monitoring
and logging and ensuring that it's doing
what you thought it would, right?
Fundamentally, can you control it, right?
So the first thing your
CFO is gonna wanna know
is can you control it?
And the second thing they're gonna want
to know is is it any
good, does it work, right?
And you know, today more than 85 percent
of agents are vibe tested, right?
So, you know, I build an
agent and then I sit there
and I go, hmm, yeah, seems
to work pretty good, right?
Which is fine, hmm, maybe not.
But you know, if I said to you, hey,
we're gonna give up on unit testing
for all our computer
science from here on out,
we're just gonna have
you try the happy path,
see if it works well, and
then just deploy it, right?
Most of us would never tolerate that.
Or maybe we would, but
our bosses might not.
But fundamentally, if you're going
to go deploy these things,
you need to know whether
or not they work, right?
I wouldn't build you a
forecast, a sales forecast,
and then say, you know, you
say, oh, how accurate is it?
And I go, I don't know, it's
pretty good, isn't it, right?
No, I would tell you
the R-squared or the AUC
or some other measure of fit.
Well, here, we want to give
you that same opportunity,
that ability to, using
evaluation, drive these things
to a point where they can be
deployed in the path of risk
and where you can
communicate their performance
quantitatively to your
colleagues and others, right?
So let's start with Unity Catalog
and a quick view on Unity Catalog,
why Unity Catalog is important.
Well, I talked a minute ago about the fact
that not only do I want to
govern access to this agent,
I actually want to govern
every single thing this agent does.
If this agent looks at
data, I want to know that.
If this agent calls an
API, I want to know that.
I want to know what it's capable of doing
and what it did on every
single time it was used, right?
And so Unity Catalog does that, right?
We not only, not only does
Unity Catalog govern tables,
it governs unstructured data,
it governs embeddings, right?
It governs tools, it
governs API calls, right?
It can govern all of these capabilities.
And when I say govern,
not only can it control
who can go do those things,
but it can log every
time they're done, right?
And recently, oh, I should
say it can govern prompts,
it can govern GenAI models and
the access to those models.
And then, most recently, we announced
it can govern MCP servers.
So you can stand up a managed
MCP server inside Databricks
and have any of the
Databricks assets, right?
Any of the queries or the
Text-to-SQL Genie Rooms
or the APIs in there, or
the tools you've built
or the queries you've built,
all of those can be represented
behind an MCP server that
then your agents can call
and access those artifacts
within Databricks.
But that's not it because
we don't just want
to be able to govern the agents
that you build on Databricks.
If we gave you the opportunity
to govern just the models on Databricks,
then everywhere you build
models, you would have
to have a separate view of how to govern
and access control and monitor them there.
So instead, what we've
done is we've made it
so you can take external MCP servers,
maybe you have an MCP server
that's part of a SaaS system.
Maybe you have an MCP server
that someone else in a different
department built, right?
You can register those MCP
servers inside Unity Catalog.
And now anything that you want your agent
to go and access can be accessed,
even if it's a separate
SaaS system, right?
Those APIs or that MCP
server can be packaged up,
registered inside Databricks,
and now your agent,
instead of going off and
calling that MCP server
will call it through Databricks,
and we'll be able to log and monitor
every single thing it does, right?
This is really when I, not
long after the pandemic struck,
I had a meeting with the
Head of Trust and Safety
at one of the world's largest retailers.
And I said to her, hey,
when the pandemic struck
and all of the human
behavioral models went bananas,
because we all thought that
toilet paper was more valuable
than gold, like, how on
earth did you prioritize
which models to retrain when?
And she kind of sheepishly
smiled at me and said,
Craig, you think we know
where all our models are?
Right, there's some laughter,
some uncomfortable laughter
in the room, right?
If that model that was
built was some forecast
for used, you know, mystery
books, maybe I don't care.
But if that model had access to APIs,
if that model could take
actions on behalf of my company,
then not monitoring it very closely
and knowing exactly what it's doing
starts to become a liability, right?
And so that's why Unity
Catalog is central to this,
is it can become that hub of
governance and monitoring,
not just of the agent itself, but of all
of the different things these
agents might want to touch.
Now, monitoring is the
second half of this, right?
Now, we run monitoring not only
for classical things
like tokens and latency
and all of these kinds of things,
but we'll actually run LLM
judges as a part of the monitor
so that you can measure things
like ongoing correctness, right?
Or you can start looking
through your logs to see, hey,
are there particular
subject matters that I tend
to get wrong more than other
subject matters, right?
And this can become a way in
which you can really start
to surgically go after the performance
of your system, right?
So that's a quick overview
of why Unity Catalog
is so important to all of this.
Now, I wanna dive into AI/BI,
and you can really think about agents
on Databricks in two ways.
One is we're building a
bunch of agents to make it so
that you can use Databricks more easily.
The second is, we're building tools so
that you can build
agents more effectively.
And so I wanted to talk
for a minute about AI/BI
because it's really central
to some of the agents
that we've been building
that are getting reused
when people build agents themselves.
First of all, we've seen
massive user growth,
five hundred percent
year over year growth.
And by the way, this AI/BI capability,
these capabilities,
they're...can't say free,
but they just cost you the
cost of the queries, right?
They don't cost you extra.
You don't have to go get a
separate contract to use this
or an addendum or anything.
You can just start using it, right?
That's part of what's driven this growth.
It allows you to have
text to visualization.
You can just say, hey, show me the sales
by region over the last
six months, you know,
you know, broken down by product
or something along those lines.
And you'll get a dashboard
and then you can filter this
dashboard, move these around,
you know, kind of do all the things
you would expect in a modern BI tool.
But you've created the entire thing
with natural language, right?
Now, we all know, I'm saying
we because I'm guessing
other data professionals in the room
that, when an executive
comes to you and says,
hey, can you build me a dashboard...
(exhales) that's a rough day.
Because not only are you
building a dashboard,
but you are now answering
an unlimited number
of deep dive questions
about that dashboard, right?
Dashboards don't create answers.
Dashboards create more questions, right?
Where people are constantly saying,
oh yeah, sales rep, why were they up?
Sales were down, why
were they down, right?
All of these questions, we
used to, when I was at Amazon,
we used to joke that, you know,
hey, I wanna know what sales were.
And as soon as you told
them, they were like,
I meant for blue things, right?
And so, how do you get ahead of that?
Well, not only can you
use natural language
to build these visualizations,
you can start talking to your data.
You can ask questions of your data, right?
You can go in and just
start saying, you know,
hey, what was it that drove sales?
I will tell you that this TXT-to-SQL,
or this TXT-to-SQL capability
or Genie Rooms, as you'll
often hear it called,
or Genie Spaces,
it has a remarkable capability
that's recently been announced,
which is it has a deep research
capability attached to it now.
So the deep research capability
won't just answer questions.
I mean, it will answer
questions about the data,
but it'll start to answer
much more complex questions.
Hey, describe to me where
the most efficient places
in my sales funnel would be for me
to invest incremental
marketing dollars, right?
And it will go through, it'll build a plan
for how it would go after this problem.
It'll check that plan with you,
and then it'll start
running the queries it needs
to across all of your tables in order
to start informing that plan.
I had an amazing moment with
a customer just two weeks ago
where he said they had a whole bunch
of supply chain data in here,
and he asked it for
some help understanding
what some of the supply chain costs
and risks would be on some
of their transpacific
transportation routes.
He hit enter, it came up
with a plan, he waited,
and then it stopped and it said, hey,
I don't have all the
data I need to do this.
I need you to give me
access to another table.
And I say that 'cause that's a huge leap
for this technology.
For this technology, and
we're seeing this both
in our system as well as in
some of the foundation models
that they're just not making stuff up
at quite the rate they were back
when we were talking about GPT-35
and what have you, right?
We can start to, it's
starting to get to a place
where we can, if we're
careful, we can start building
that trust a lot more effectively.
And so, and then finally in
private preview right now,
we have a data science agent.
Now, I'll tell you that
on that last slide,
that TXT-to-SQL deep dive capability,
that one hit home for me
because that was my first job in tech.
I was the guy who wrote really good SQL,
who could answer the
questions that the VP had,
and I could answer them
quickly and effectively.
And that got me a lot of credibility
and notoriety from the
VP, which was great.
That's now being done by the agent.
Well, now we have a data science agent.
This data science agent
will help you analyze data,
help you determine what
features might be useful
for predicting a problem,
and then will actually go
and help you train the model, right?
We want to make it so that you could have
text to machine learning model.
We're not there yet, now it's
a collaborative back and forth
with you and the system,
but we're really excited
about some of the things we're
seeing from this already.
And my guess is that
by next time this year,
we'll be sitting there saying
like, hey, this is as easy
as asking a question of your data.
Maybe, maybe a year and a half, we'll see.
And then lastly, we have a
whole series of SQL capabilities
that can be used to go
and run GenAI, right?
Things like ai_parse_document,
which you'll hear about
very shortly, ai_query.
So ai_query allows you to run
any arbitrary prompt as part of a query.
So maybe you have a table
that you wanna score,
every row of that table,
or you want to summarize
every blurb in that table
or something like that.
That can easily be done with a single line
of SQL at this point.
So now we move into the meat
of it, into Agent Bricks,
into this new way of thinking
about building agents.
This really evaluation-centric
way of building agents.
It's hard to build AI
agents today, we know this.
We know a lot of companies will come to us
and say, hey, we've
tried, we've struggled.
You know, we're having a hard time.
It's even harder to build
high quality AI agents, right?
And so when we think about quality,
it comes down to evaluation.
And this is just a quick
view of our eval stack,
but the key to this eval system,
so we built this long about a year
before we built Agent Bricks
and the key to this eval system was,
see those little red circles?
Those little red circles
are where the judges failed
that line in the eval and the key is that
if you click on one of
those little red circles,
you don't just get, you get a
description of why it failed
and not, you get, you know, hey,
here's why we think it failed.
Here's the input and the
output at the specific step
of the agent that we saw
that we believe failed
and most importantly,
here's what you should go do
to fix it, right, as soon
as we had that concept
of here's what you should go do
to fix it, everything changed
and the reason everything changed
is it allowed us to build Agent Bricks.
Now, what is Agent Bricks?
Well, in the market today, you
can kind of think about cost
or about complexity versus quality.
And what we have in the
market today is we have these
no-code builders, right?
Where, you know, hey,
they're super easy to use
and they produce kind of static,
low quality agents, right?
And you kind of have to put up
with whatever they produced.
And they're great, by the way,
if what you're doing is creating a system
that prioritizes your emails
and writes you a summary
of all your emails from last
night, great, go for it.
But if you're wanting to put something
in the path of risk, you
need something better.
And so we have these
complex, very complex kind
of DIY agents that are
very high quality, right?
We can tune them and continue to tune them
until we get the quality we want.
But they're really complex
and difficult to build.
Ultimately, our goal with Agent Bricks
is the impossible in-between.
We wanna make it easy for high quality.
We wanna make it so that
you can very quickly
and very easily spin up
an agent that performs
or that you can then
tune until you can get it
to perform at kind of
whatever your exit criteria is
for your use case, right?
Evaluation is difficult, so we
immediately went after that.
There's too many knobs.
And when I say there's too many knobs,
there's actually not a lot of knobs.
The problem is that the
state-of-the-art methods
for building these agents is changing
every two to eight weeks, depending on
what kind of agent you're building.
So, you know, what we
see is usually the people
who are building these
agents are app developers.
And what we see is they come in
and they do a great job
of building an agent,
but they may not be up on
what the latest research
was released last month.
And so what Agent Bricks is
designed to do (clears throat)
is it's designed to take
that latest research
and those latest techniques
and bring them into the system, right?
And then, so that you don't
have to worry about the knobs,
you don't have to worry about
how you're gonna structure
your vector search queries
'cause we'll just take
care of that for you.
And then finally, there's a trade off
of cost versus quality.
We all know that GenAI can
be a costly endeavor, right?
And so having the ability
to be really deliberate
about how I'm going to spend
and how I'm going to trade off
cost versus quality is something
that's really important.
If you're all of a sudden
going to put something
in maybe an externally facing capacity
where you could end up
with, you know, thousands,
tens of thousands, maybe if you're lucky,
hundreds of thousands or
millions of queries, right?
And so with that, we have a series
of Databricks, or sorry, of Agent Bricks.
And those, those agent
bricks are really designed
as kind of templated patterns
that you can come in
and start using, right?
Hey, you need a RAG, you
need basically a RAG system
or a knowledge assistant, great.
Grab the knowledge assistant Agent Brick
and you're off to the races.
Now we start with information extraction.
Information extraction takes
your unstructured documents.
Maybe you've got receipts,
maybe you've got shipping documents,
maybe you've got contracts, right?
It takes those and breaks
them into structured data.
Literally, you go upload your documents
and then into Agent Bricks,
it identifies the schema,
says here's all the fields I'm gonna pull
out of these documents,
describes to you each field.
And then you have a choice, do
you want to keep that field?
Do you wanna erase it, is
it important, is it not?
Do you wanna add other fields
and describe them for us?
Right, and then we're off to the races.
Now with all of the Agent Bricks,
the idea is that once you've built it,
unfortunately; you're not done
'cause then what we're gonna do
is we're gonna start giving you examples
and we're gonna start
asking you for examples
of, hey, ask me a question
that you would expect
it to be able to answer.
Or here's some synthetic questions
I would expect it to be able to answer.
What do you think of these responses?
And you'll sit there
and go, well, one, two,
and three are good, four is not so good,
and five is a train wreck.
You know, and so we'll sit there
and as soon as you give us that feedback,
we're gonna go tune the system
and then come back to you
and say, hey, let's try
another few examples.
And we're gonna keep doing
that back and forth with you
until it gets to a point
where you're really excited
and satisfied by the outputs, right?
And so making it really easy to just kind
of take those documents and
build them into structured data.
Knowledge assistant,
same idea except for RAG.
So you have a corpus of text that you want
to make searchable and you wanna be able
to answer questions about
that text and what have you.
Great, upload the text into
Agent Bricks, start to engage
with the system on asking it questions
and it giving you responses
so that you can give it feedback.
And by the way, when you say one, two,
and three are good, four needs work
and five is a train wreck,
we're actually gonna ask you
why are four and five bad?
And we're not just going to go and guess.
You're gonna tell us, hey,
four is using outdated information
and five, like it totally ignored one
of the policies we have, right?
And we can take that feedback
and we can drive that direct feedback
back into the system, right?
We can more easily reason
over our knowledge, right?
Automatic vector search
creation and optimization.
All you have to do is upload the data
and then talk to us for
a while about whether
or not the responses are
responses you're excited by.
And then multi-agent supervisor,
this one to me is the most exciting one.
Multi-agent supervisor takes
a series of other agents,
MCP servers, tools, other capabilities,
and is able to work large kind
of longer running workflows
over these MCP servers,
tools, and other agents, right?
Really allowing you to build
some pretty remarkable capabilities,
which we'll see here very shortly, right?
You can see here, you
know, being able to talk
over both data and unstruc- you know,
both structured and
unstructured data, right?
Can I ask questions of both my query
or both my unstructured data as well
as my policies and manuals, right?
You know, can I build tools so
that I can drive higher levels
of determinism in my agent, right?
And then ultimately, we
have the ability for you
to code your own agent as well
and the ability for you to kind of dive in
and use, you know, all of
the most popular libraries
and what have you, to
go build your own agent
if you prefer to do that.
So the great news is we're seeing some
extraordinarily high quality.
This is a comparison to two of the clouds,
neither of which we are
representing here today.
And so you can see how we were
able to beat this blue cloud
and this rainbow cloud
in their efforts on RAG.
And that not only does
our performance beat them
because we have some of those
latest techniques built in,
but our performance continues
to improve as we keep
that continuous learning
loop going, right?
So how are we able to do this, right?
Let's say you're building that
classic kind of, you know,
HR chat bot with, you know, hey,
I want it to answer all of my HR policies
and someone asks it a
question about vacation time
and you say, you know, hey,
that's the wrong answer.
Wait, that's before we changed the policy
back in May of 2020.
So you tell the system, hey, I want you
to ignore all data before May of 2020.
So the system goes in and it does that,
it changes the what's
available in the vector search,
it adds, you know, parameters
to all of the tool calling.
It builds LLM judges to make sure
that moving forward, we measure
any time we pull data
from before then, right?
So that feedback we're
actually going to use
to build judges to ensure that we meet it
and then it's gonna reoptimize
the entire workflow, right?
This is a huge step in steerability.
I would argue that in a
year, probably in a year,
maybe a year and a half,
depending on the level of urgency,
I think this is the product that all
of the major vendors are gonna
be competing with, right?
How can I use natural
language to both build
and tune my agent, right?
That's the product that we all are looking
for and that we all want.
And so really excited to
be able to deliver that
to you today in beta.
With that, I'm gonna invite Nic up
to give us a quick demo of all of this.
- Awesome, thank you, Craig.
That is epic, for sure.
(audience claps)
It won't be the last time he's
up, so you can still get him
for Q&A at the end but he deserves
a round of applause, for sure.
All right, so I'm gonna take
you through a whirlwind tour
of a lot of what you just saw,
but to kind of tee it up, who
here is excited to go home
after re:Invent and
uncrumple all your receipts
and go start submitting
your expense reports?
Show of hands, all right,
security, no, I'm kidding.
So I'm gonna use that as an
excuse to kind of show you
how I built this end-to-end on Databricks,
starting from, I literally took a picture
of my receipts and all the way to the end
to where I have something
submitted and approved.
So we're actually gonna start off,
and Craig alluded to this a little bit,
but Unity Catalog really is the foundation
of everything across
Databricks, whether it's AI,
whether it's our ETL,
everything both starts
and ends in Unity Catalog.
And so, this demo's also
gonna start in Unity Catalog.
Unity Catalog can store tables, volumes,
functions, all sorts of things.
And so what you're looking
at is a Unity Catalog volume
that I've uploaded all
of my receipts into.
So, you can see I click in,
it'll give me a nice preview
as long as the internet's a little snappy.
Yeah, cool, okay, so you'll see
not even a great picture, right?
It's like kinda at a weird angle.
Now, if I wanna start
doing something with this,
I need to actually extract
all the information
out of this receipt, now a few years ago,
that might've been pretty challenging,
but today, especially using
Agent Bricks, it's super easy.
So the first thing I'm gonna do over here
on the bottom left, I'm
gonna click into Agents
and that's gonna take us
to our Agent Bricks page.
Now you'll see there are a lot of them
and we're actually gonna touch,
I think every single one
of them through here.
But we're gonna start off
with information extraction.
And here you'll see there's two buttons.
We've got Use PDFs, and
then we've got Build.
And that's generally
because we're gonna take
a little bit of a two step process.
So first, we need to take from images
and get the data from
images into an actual table.
So for this we can click Use PDFs.
It's as easy as pointing it to a volume
like you just saw, here's all
my receipts, can it confirm?
And then I just tell it
where I want it stored.
I gave it my destination
table, I can rename it.
I've already run this before, you know,
in the interest of time.
And so if I were to hit Start Import,
what you're gonna see is this.
You're gonna get now your raw parse data.
This is what the information
extraction was able
to kind of pull out of that image.
And then you're gonna get this kind
of semi-structured data, right?
You've got a block of text,
it's got the information
that was in that receipt, but it's not
in a really robust format that you can
really reliably start building on top of.
So if we go back to our agent page,
that's when we would
click this build button.
So what build is gonna take us
to is actually creating the second part
of this information extraction agent.
So we're gonna point it to
this table that's the output
of the one we just saw.
We're gonna tell it where the text is
and it'll actually auto
generate the sample
of what it thinks that you want
to actually extract out of this data.
Now when you hit Create
Agent, what it's gonna do
is it's actually gonna go
through a couple of them
and it's gonna extract
what it assumed you wanted.
And on the right hand side,
it's gonna give you a
whole bunch of definitions
for the values that it extracted.
You can now go and tweak these.
If you say, uh, you know what, location
for me needs to be only the city, right?
I don't need to know the exact restaurant.
And so you can kind of
come in here and tweak.
And then, the really cool part
is you can add new fields.
For example, if you might
need to know the number
of desserts, you can actually
add a totally new field.
You can describe what is in that field,
and this might be a little
bit foreshadowing later,
but it will figure out
how to pull that data,
using the examples you gave.
Now going back to what Craig
said about evaluations,
how do you know that this
extraction is working?
How do you know that the fields you wanted
to pull are actually being pulled?
We will automatically
build benchmarks for you,
and these benchmarks will look
at all of your extractions
and it'll use LLMs as judges to tell, hey,
this sample output
normally looks like this.
I'll give you an example for
this one that failed for match,
it says, look, the ground truth example
names the restaurant
name along with the city,
but this prediction only
has a city and state.
So now I can go and figure
out, oh, okay, cool,
I need to go update my description
because it doesn't know what
exactly I want it to give me.
I want just the city and state.
Once you're happy, you can
click this optimize button.
And I did promise that we are gonna make
your agents less expensive.
And I'll show you what the
output of that looks like.
Once you actually run the optimization,
it'll go away for an hour or so
and it'll run a whole bunch of
different techniques in order
to take your kind of, your
samples that you gave it
and the kind of relatively
big and high quality model
and fine tune that down to
a way more efficient model
while keeping the quality the same.
So you see that our
throughput went up massively
and our quality didn't even drop.
So it's much less expensive to run.
And now you can actually run
this on huge sets of data.
So now we've extracted this data, right?
We went from on the left
where we had this kind
of semi-structured block of text
to now this beautiful-structured
JSON on the right,
and now we've got all of our
receipts nicely extracted
and we can start figuring out
how to submit these things.
Now in order to do that,
we're gonna tab over here
to Unity Catalog again.
Now I said earlier, right, Unity Catalog,
it holds a lot of different things.
So if I go to volumes, you see
that we've got our receipts,
that's where we uploaded
all of our receipts.
We've got travel policies,
that's gonna come in handy later.
We've got some tables.
This is where we've parsed
those receipts out into
and it's also where the
information extraction agent
is dumping the final, beautiful JSON.
And we've also got functions.
So functions can be either Python or SQL.
You define them, you register
them into Unity Catalog.
And now what it lets you
do is really easily bind
these functions to your agents
so that your agents can call them
with proper authentication,
thanks to Unity Catalog.
Just so you can kind of take
a look at what these are,
they can be as simple as this.
So this is just a simple SQL query
and all it's doing is
it's grabbing the data
from both my receipts parse table
and the information extraction agent.
So now what we can do, we're
gonna go right back to agents
and we're gonna use also
my personal favorite agent,
the multi-agent supervisor.
We've got data, we've got some functions
that do stuff with that data.
We want an agent to actually do this all
for us, so we can hit Build
and now we can start
piecing together this agent.
Now I've kind of, I
ran this in the hallway
like 30 minutes ago just so
we don't have to wait here,
but I wanna show you first the
configuration of the agent.
So on the left hand side,
we've given it a really light description,
it helps users process expenses.
And then we've added two sub-agents.
These are just the two Unity Catalog
functions that I showed you earlier.
They allow this agent to
retrieve the parse data
that we looked at in the
information extraction,
and they allow it to
hit your expense, API,
whatever company you might use in order
to actually send the payload off
to your expense agency for approval.
So now we can tell it,
hey, can you retrieve
and summarize my dinner
expenses from Las Vegas?
So it will go through, it
calls that first function,
get uploaded expenses,
it'll give you a nice,
very clean summary, hey, you spent,
you know, about two hundred
dollars on dinners, awesome.
So I said, hey, can we go
ahead and submit these, right?
Naively, I thought that
in just about 10 minutes,
I had nailed this, so I'm like,
all right, we're good to go.
Yeah, go ahead and submit 'em.
And it said, sure, absolutely, goes ahead.
It knows how to do it, right?
And another thing that's
kind of hard to show here,
but in those functions,
it actually gives a lot
of descriptive kind of definitions
of what that function does.
Agent Bricks will automatically bring
that in thanks to Unity Catalog.
So it just knows how to use
these functions really well.
So it goes ahead, it submits some
and it tells me, hey, you're all good.
All three of your expenses are in, cool.
Let's fast forward a week, right?
All of a sudden, I get my
expense deposited in my account
and I'm like, that seems
a lot less than I spent.
So I go and I'm like, huh, I need to,
I need to go figure out what happened.
So I'm gonna go into Genie.
Now, Genie is our TXT-to-SQL solution
and I'm gonna bring in one of my tables,
historical expenses, so
this is where I'm pulling
from my expense agency just to see
kind of what was submitted
and what happened with it.
And so now I can actually ask it, hey,
can you show me if any of my
recent expenses were rejected?
And so it will go, it will do its analysis
as Craig showed earlier, it'll
even give you the game plan
and the reasoning that it used
and it came back and it said, hey,
you have two recent
expenses that were rejected.
Both were declined due to the
policy on desserts, right?
So if we look over here,
rejection reason, whoa,
more than one dessert per dinner
violates the travel and expense policy.
And I was a naughty boy in Vegas.
I was getting double
desserts, so let's fix that.
Now, it wasn't the agent's fault,
I just didn't give it
enough context, right?
It didn't know what the travel
policy was, I never told it.
So now we're gonna go
back into Agent Bricks
and we're gonna use our
knowledge assistant.
So if you go into Knowledge Assistant,
you'll see we've made a
very, very simple one.
We gave it a description, it's meant
to help users submit
valid expense reports.
And all we've done is pointed it
to our policy documentation,
again, in that Unity Catalog volume.
It figures out how to parse that PDF
and now I can actually ask it directly
hey, can you give me a summary
of why I can't get two desserts at dinner?
And, if it seems like I'm
a little upset about it,
trust your instincts.
So you'll see, it'll even
tell you what it's thinking,
it'll go, it'll pull all the information
that it needs from our policy.
And one thing that's really cool
is it'll even come with receipts.
So you can actually look to see exactly
what it referenced within our policy
in case you wanna double check
that it did everything correctly,
or if you wanna copy and paste it
and send a mean message on Slack,
asking somebody why this exists.
Now, because we have
this knowledge assistant,
we can go back into our
multi-agent supervisor, right?
And now, we're gonna add
this knowledge assistant
as another sub-agent that it can call.
And while we're at it, so here you'll see
that this one has a
little bit more, right?
We've got our travel expense agent,
this is our knowledge assistant.
We can also add that
Genie Space that we used
to figure out if the
expense was valid or not.
So now our agent can call
Genie to retrieve data
and then we still kept
our original two functions
so we can still pull
and submit our expenses.
So now when we ask it, hey,
can you retrieve any
rejected expenses from Vegas?
It will go through and
it's gonna pass that off
to Genie just like I did.
It's gonna get the two, you know,
expenses back that were declined.
It's gonna tell you
why they were declined.
And then I said, all
right, can we go ahead
and fix these by removing
the less expensive dessert,
recalculating the totals?
Sure it goes, it checks
with our travel assistant
to make sure that we're
following the policies correctly.
And we're just gonna
kinda skip through this.
It's telling you, hey, all right,
we applied these
corrections, we resubmitted,
and at the end, it'll tell
you, hey look, you know,
corrected amounts are gonna
be a little bit less, right?
But now they're actually gonna pass.
And so I've submitted them
and then, at the end, I can actually ask,
hey, can you give me a detailed breakdown
of my Las Vegas expenses to my Genie Room?
It can go, it can pull all
of the expenses that I've submitted.
Tell me that I had a total
of three dinners approved
in Las Vegas, all categorized as meals.
Now I'm feeling much
better, but I'm not done.
There's one more thing I want to do.
What happens if I share this
and now the next person comes along?
They're gonna run into
the same issue I did.
So what I can actually do is
I can go to Improve Quality
and I can start a labeling session.
Now what I can do is I can
tell it a question, hey,
can you process a dinner
expense that has two desserts?
Now, the reason I'm doing this is
'cause now I can give it
guidelines, I can tell it
whenever anything
similar to this is asked,
this is what you need to do.
You need to remove the
less expensive dessert
and recalculate the
totals before submitting.
So now I've not only fixed
the problem for myself,
but I've improved the agent
for anyone that comes along.
And you can imagine that as
you start scaling these agents,
you can have more and more people doing
these review sessions.
You can bring in your
subject matter experts
and you can easily merge
all of that into your agent
and I have written no code
doing this whole thing.
Now, obviously, I do need
to know how JSON works,
so it's not a totally no-code solution,
but it makes it so you can
iterate so much faster.
So with that, I think
it's time to hand it off
to Vikram and Marcos from Conde Nast
who are gonna show us all
the awesome things that
they've been doing.
(audience claps)
- Perfect.
- Can everyone hear me?
Yes, great, fantastic.
I'm Vikram, this is Marcos.
And thank you, Craig
and Nico for having us
and to my incredible account team.
Thank you, Nassim, for
having us here as well.
So you've heard Craig talk a lot
about how TXT-to-SQL empowers businesses.
So we had a similar problem.
So earlier this year, my
CEO came to me and said,
look, you built this incredible
data platform on Databricks.
Why is it that I cannot do self-serve
or self-service myself, right?
So we set about trying to figure out
can we put TXT-to-SQL to work
in our specific use case.
So that's the objective
and that is the journey
that we wanna talk about
but before we get there,
we want to talk a little bit
about who we are as Conde Nast.
We are a global media powerhouse.
You would definitely know
us through our brands.
Vogue, Vanity Fair, The
New Yorker, Acquired,
for those of you who are looking
at tech deals over the
weekend, Conde Nast Traveler,
if you're into food,
obviously you're looking
at Bon Appetit, you know, and others.
We operate in 12 countries,
we have 22 global brands.
And we went through an interesting
transformation in 2019.
So prior to 2019, we were actually
two separate operating companies.
There was Conde Nast US and
then there was Conde Nast
in the rest of the world.
And the two of them didn't
share anything in terms
of process, in terms of technology.
So in 2019, this was prior
to me joining Conde Nast,
somebody made the decision, look,
we are gonna unify everything
and we are gonna become
one global company.
At that point, 70 percent of
our revenue came from print.
It was only 30 percent digital.
So we started the unification process,
and it was more than
just the data platforms,
it was a total transformation
of our entire system
around our entire technology ecosystem.
And today our revenue is 70 percent
digital and 30 percent print.
So in about five to six years,
we have actually reversed
where our money comes from.
We support multiple revenue streams,
whether it's commercial advertising,
whether it is subscriptions.
We do live events, we
do puzzles and games.
So our product line is very, very broad.
So what I'm literally
trying to tell you here
is the problem that we
were trying to solve
with our data strategy was pretty vast.
We needed to adapt that data strategy
or future proof our data strategy
so we could evolve the
data strategy to keep,
to enable the business as it evolved.
So 2020, that's our data landscape.
It was, yeah, it's completely
decentralized, obviously.
We lacked any form of
data governance, privacy,
data lineage, business
semantics, you name it.
I mean, none of it really existed.
It was purely in its infancy
at that point, right?
In fact, we relied fairly heavily
on a spreadsheet driven process.
If you wanted to get insights or KPIs
about how our brands
were performing globally.
2020, we made a strategic decision
to partner with Databricks
and they've been a
tremendous partner for us.
We remediated a lot of the challenges
that are laid out previously.
And what you're seeing today
is a centralized data Lakehouse
where we have connected
all of our data sources.
But really what this
enables us to think about
is how do we put this data to use, right?
How do we drive insights?
How do we drive, you know,
how do we report on KPIs?
But more importantly, it has enabled us
to build data products on top of this.
As we think about a Customer
360, our identity is fine.
And how do we activate
both of those, right?
Those are very important for us.
How do we plug AI and
machine learning into this?
How do we drive hyper-personalized
audience experiences?
How do we drive experimentation?
All of this is again, built on top
of the Databricks foundations
that Craig spoke about
just a few minutes ago.
But there's more to it, right?
So this year, again, I
was asked, hey, look,
what's the AI strategy?
You know, what are we doing about AI?
And I think that's a question
that everybody's been asking.
An answer, and really
maybe I'll try and explain
this diagram a little bit
so that it makes sense.
We ended up building our
centralized data warehouse,
so you could see that in the orange.
We've started to do things
on top of that, right?
But on the x-axis, as
you look at how we want
to democratize our data,
how we want everybody
to use the data that's
sitting within the Lakehouse
as close to the Lakehouse as possible,
you know, we have a little bit
of way to go in that journey.
And the same thing with activation.
But the point that we also
wanna make here is that,
as we transformed our, as
the business transformed,
and as we transformed and brought in all
of our data sources into the Lakehouse,
we went through a fundamental
shift in a variety of areas.
And that changed how our
KPIs were constructed, right?
At the end of the day, that was important.
We had to build trust, yeah,
and that was important.
So maybe the point I'm
trying to make here is
if you don't have trusted data,
if you don't have a ground
truth for your data,
your AI strategy is not gonna
be successful as it scales.
It may work for a couple of use cases,
but, you know, think long and hard
about your AI strategy
independent of a data strategy.
And this is our learning
that we have taken from this journey.
As I said previously, our,
we have multiple brands,
multiple markets, different revenue lines,
every brand chooses to monetize
its revenue differently,
even within a specific brand.
Sometimes, the brand will do something
a little bit different, so as an example,
Vogue as an app will have
a different monetization,
monetization strategy, excuse
me, than say Vogue.com.
So when we think about all of that,
our data happens to be pretty dynamic.
It's very, very disparate and diverse
and it's pretty complicated.
The volume is fairly high as well.
We support both real time
and batch, as I said.
And of course we have leveraged everything
that the Lakehouse offers to us as well.
We've centered around the
medallion architecture.
We use the Unity Catalog
heavily for governance
and everything else that
comes with the Unity Catalog.
- Oh, and when you look at Conde Nast
and how our business areas are organized,
thank you, you're gonna
see that each of the areas,
they have their own analytics
team, they have independence,
ownership, and they have like
a deep functional knowledge.
And what we questioned of ourself was
how can we enable collaboration
and use collaboration of these teams
so we can drive value faster?
And we created like a, what we call
a federated collaboration
strategy with them.
So we partner with the business areas,
with the analytics teams.
We, they keep their
independence, autonomy,
speed, and deep functional knowledge,
but we try to create like a set
of unifying tools,
frameworks, and data sets
that it can use and move faster.
We work with them to
unify also the semantic
of what they're doing,
data quality frameworks,
and other things like that.
And we moved that on, so
the areas are exploring data
within Databricks, they
are playing with it.
And then we receive the question, okay,
how do we do to democratize our data?
And this is where we start
keeping the same philosophy
so they can build and they
can enable, we enable them
and empower them to create
their own TXT-to-SQL agents.
So each of these independent areas
started creating their TXT-to-SQL agents
and rolling that out
for their stakeholders.
So we have like executives
asking questions
to the data, having their
charts and playing with it
and learning a lot and changing
a little bit the culture.
After you do that, you,
so the question is, okay,
we look at the log of questions, we see
that a few questions,
they cannot be answered
or they cannot be answered
by one specific agent.
And how do we connect these agents?
And this is where we go to our super agent
or our multi-agent supervisor
that's a Databricks app
connected to Agent Bricks
that uses the different agents
of the Agent Bricks that defines us.
The multi-agent supervisor defines
which agents they're gonna
use, get to the answers
and get back with the result.
We use, we also connect to
Alation, that's our catalog tool,
using instructions and
judgment and guardrails
on top of the multi-agent supervisor.
And that's usually,
that's synced with Unity.
And so now, if an executive
wants to access our data,
they go to the Databricks
app, put their questions,
Agent Bricks decides
which agents to engage,
we get the answer and we go back.
Very nice in the PowerPoint,
but Vikram is gonna show us a little bit
like how that works in real life.
- Yes.
(attendee coughs)
- Everyone can still hear
me, so, all right, great.
We start with the app screen
and I think Nicolas pointed
out how to build apps.
So I'm not gonna get into this.
And again, for the sake of brevity,
we've actually gone through
and done the work here.
So I'm just gonna walk
through this very quickly.
So as I said, we have multiple brands,
every brand has different
revenue strategies.
We have subscription brands,
and, in this case, we are gonna talk about
how the subscription brands are performing
versus what is expected.
As you can see at the prompt,
at the very top there,
not sure, yeah, there we go.
Wonder if I should zoom
in or if everyone's okay.
And that is the prompt
and that is then analyzed
by the subscription.
So maybe a little bit of insight
into how the agents themselves are built.
Subscription includes everything
that you want to know about the brand,
and it includes information
such as the channels
that the consumers came in on.
So, and that's kind of important as we go
through the demo, the second agent
that we have speaks about
audience and audience includes
how our audience is consuming our content,
but it doesn't necessarily
talk about subscriptions
or anything revenue specific.
So when we run that, it runs through
and it comes back with the
following response, right?
It provides some insight into
how the site is actually performing.
And in this case, it's focused
on Wired and it's saying,
look, Wired actually added 70
thousand site subscriptions,
but in 2025, it, we've
more than doubled it.
I do want to caution everybody,
this is not real data, this is demo data.
We are not allowed to share our revenue
and subscription numbers publicly.
We are a privately held company.
So now, so it's important for us
to go a little bit further,
so The New Yorker happens
to be yet another subscription brand.
So again, I went back to the agents
and said, look, tell me
how my top two brands,
subscription brands are doing.
And now it comes back and says, okay,
The New Yorker actually has, obviously,
it has more subscribers,
it has about a million give or take.
That's generally public knowledge.
So I'm just sharing
that but then it starts
to get into the comparison
between the brands, right?
So here it's talking about, yeah, sure,
the absolute numbers for
The New Yorker are higher,
higher but Wired shows more growth, right?
All of this is like, yeah, sure.
I mean, you can get all
of this via any sort
of dashboard, et cetera,
right, that's great.
But now let's get in a little bit deeper
and we are gonna ask it the question,
what is driving Wire's year to year growth
inside subscriptions, right?
So again, for the sake of brevity,
I've already gone ahead and run it.
And now it comes back and says, look,
you wanna look at what
the key growth drivers are
and, you remember, I shared
a little bit about a brand
and how traffic gets to
our properties, right?
And this says, look, the
top contributing channels
happen to be social media.
We see a lot of growth there.
Direct traffic, happy
to explain these terms,
but search, you know, it's
generally okay, it's doing fine.
But new channels have started to emerge,
and this is very true for media
and entertainment in general.
This could be driven off of newsletters
and other subscriptions
but AI traffic has started
to add a little bit of volume
and it's driving a little
bit, a few more subscriptions.
Now we want to get a little bit
deeper into the channel mix.
So fine, you've told me that,
hey, you're getting a lot
of traffic from social
media, that's great,
but what specifically within social media?
And that's where we come back
with the following, right?
So I didn't necessarily
speak about conversion rates,
but I'm, again, happy to
get into all of these,
but these are very specific
to media and entertainment.
So it says, look, search
decreased significantly,
direct traffic increased, social group,
strategic referral group,
new channels have come in.
And then it starts talking
about conversion rate performance, right?
Social has the most, has
shown the most improvement.
Direct traffic and direct traffic
for those who are uninitiated
with the entertainment
terms is when you type
the actual page or the URL
and search is, you know,
you go to Bing or Google,
and that's really what you're doing.
But the notable declines are email, right?
Okay, so we are doing something wrong
with our newsletter strategy.
Now whether we should be doing more,
maybe it's a content thing,
maybe it's not a content thing.
Hard to tell again, right?
Display, hmm, not doing that great either.
Google Discover, again, right?
So it provides us with
a neat little summary
of, hey, look, we are starting
to see shifts in the way the traffic
is consuming our audience.
So now if you're the CEO of the company
and you're looking at this, you are going,
yeah, okay, that makes sense.
Now you can start talking to the rest
of your leadership team about
what the strategy here needs
to be, what we should be focusing on
and what we should be
spending our dollars on.
I dunno how much time we have,
we have just about a minute.
So continue on?
- We should wrap this up.
- Yeah, so we should,
why don't you wrap up with the...?
- Okay, can I go then?
- Yeah.
- Cool.
(equipment rustles)
And what have we learned
like in this journey?
One thing is that, what you probably
are listening everywhere, that
if you don't have good data,
you cannot, you're not
gonna have good results.
But be open because you can
create curated data sets
and plug in your TXT-to-SQL on top
of the curated data sets and also prepare,
be aware that you may need
to prepare those data sets
to work with TXT-to-SQL.
On the user questions, imagine
that the agent is gonna,
if you're using TXT-to-SQL,
is gonna provide SQL
outputs for your questions.
So if you ask something that
could not be answered by a SQL,
you're not gonna get the answer.
And when you are building the multi-agent,
remember that you can add instructions
and guardrails to that layer.
We forgot, so the way we know
that all the data is tweaked
is because we added
instructions for the multi-agent
and the multi-agent applies
that to all of the data.
Some of the user questions,
they are not gonna be,
they require additional
training or guardrails.
So you can put an instruction saying like,
if you don't have complete data,
do not answer to the question.
When you're building advanced analytics,
you may need additional
tables and functions
and check when you have a new use case,
if it's gonna be like an optimal solution
to use TXT-to-SQL or if you
need something different.
And the final one, so what we have seen.
With this, we increase
a lot time to value.
So each of the individual groups
are building their own agents,
improving their own agents,
their own agents and moving super fast.
We have senior executives
accessing our data
and our agents and we look at the logs,
we understand what's not being answered,
and we use that as an
input to new requirements.
So we create like kind of
a flywheel of adoption.
We have like new requirements,
better data sets,
better new questions,
things that we cannot,
so we do a new data set.
And that has fundamentally changed the way
that most of our senior
executives interact with the data.
We see that before they were
like looking at the dashboard
as a freezing thing and
now they have the dialogue
and that really generates a transformation
on how we interact with
our data in the company.
Greg, thank you guys. (laughs)
(audience claps)
- With that...
A couple quick actions, one,
give Databricks a try, two,
(attendee laughs)
conduct work to ping us and
we're happy to come onsite
and do a workshop with
you on these topics.
You know, introduce the team
and kinda show them Agent Bricks
and walk through some
of the best practices.
And then three, get
some training solutions
and accelerators, you know,
you can, there are training,
there are online training classes as well
as some accelerators attached to our blogs
that help you get started on this.
And four, when you fill
out your evaluation
on re:Invent, give us the highest score
of any session you went to, all right?
So yeah, that's, that's it.
Unfortunately, we are out of time,
so we'll do some Q&A down here
for anyone who has questions
and then when we get kicked out,
we'll move out into the hall.
So, but thank you very
much for joining us today.
(audience claps)